you realize that the energy savings
significant
have nothing to do with turning off the light
or use instant coffee cups
so what is significant
there are five major positions in fact
in the machines that work for us
energy and therefore the machines that work for us
there is a first big post that is moved
cars, planes,
trains,
boats etc.
so you have to save travel time
if you want to save energy
typically go from the car to the bike
go from the car to the bus
from the car to the train
from the car to walking
from plane to train
finally here are some things like that
the second position which is significant
it is the comfort of the housing
so this is the energy we use at home
to heat us up and operate
the entire fleet of household appliances
that is,
our domestic slaves
it is necessary to see that the smallest soup mixer
it is four cyclists
that come out of the mixer
when you press the work button
stop
I'm not talking about washing machines,
elevators etc.
the third significant item
is to make everything we buy
so as soon as we go to buy clothes
a toy for christmas etc
there is industry that has worked behind it
this is the third significant post
the fourth significant post is eating
so this is not so much a post
significant in energy expenditure
but we still depend a lot on oil to
this for example
one truck out of three in France
carries something that is eaten
so we are very dependent on oil
all over the channel
and finally the fifth position a little significant
is the public services
public services and services
because when we go to school
we benefit from the heating of the school
the construction of the elementary school for the hospital etc.
the care system for example in France
it is 8 of our carbon footprint